frédéric dabi ça fait un petit peu
sourire quand on sait que benjamin
griveaux est plutôt favori pour
remplacer christophe castaner comme
porte parole rappelant qu'il avait été
porte parole du mouvement en marche pour
l'élection présidentielle
qu'est ce que vous en pensez clairement
on est sur un sujet qui n'intéresse pas
vraiment les français on en parlait
avant l'antenne on va parfois demain ou
parler on va en reparler dans le sens où
il ya une sorte d'action mou d'équations
qui fait les français s'intéressent au
sujet qui les concerne donc la vie gay
l'avis des organisations partisanes les
concerne ne peut y intéressent le ona
dans notre baromètre il faut fiducial
pour match une question extrêmement
intéressante
une question peut être avoir tous les
mois qui concerne les conversations des
français de quoi de quoi parler français
et systématiquement les événements liés
à la vie des partis arrivent en bas de
tableau le mois dernier justement la
probable élection de christophe castaner
ne recueillait que 16 ou 17 % de gens
nés par les mêmes devoirs et un produit
pas comme les autres mettant en scène un
parti qui n'est pas comme les autres
c'est un parti qui est pour tous pour
les français une page blanche et qu' une
surface de projection mais c'est surtout
et là on n'est pas seulement dans le
nouveau monde comme les parties de
l'ancien monde c'est un parti
majoritaire et on sait très bien que les
français à l'époque de l'ump pour
nicolas sarkozy à l'époque du ps pour
offre soit on projette l'image qu'ils
ont du gouvernement sur le parti
majoritaire c'est peut-être l'enjeu pour
en marche et pour christophe castaner
s'est créé peut-être démarche de
différenciation et créer des éléments
d'image qui pour l'instant n'existe pas
et puis pourquoi je pense que les
français s'y intéresse pas ce que je
veux dire un peu trivialement ya pas de
problème il ya cinq ans elle même époque
on parlait de couacs à tous les étages
sur tous les échelons ministériel là on
avait fait une enquête la semaine
dernière dans le journal du dimanche où
on voyait très bien on avait testé la la
satisfaction surtout des ministres il ya
très peu de différence auprès des
ministres les plus populaires et ceux
qui sont des moins impopulaire ce
gouvernement apparaît un peu comme un
pack un peu comme un choc parce que
c'est un gouvernement d'experts parce
que beaucoup n'y sont très peu connus
donc je dirais qu'à six mois six mois
après l'entrée en fonction des manuels
macron la question d'un remaniement
autant il pouvait s'imposer avec une
certaine acuité dans lé quinquennat
précédent autant c'est une question qui
apparaît relativement secondaire